All right, so let's open up Ultrix.
Drag in an input data tool and connect
to the HotelLoyaltyData.csv file.
The data has been aggregated
to a customer level and
has many variables
about these customers.
The first thing I'm going to
do is connect to a select tool
that allows me to view the structure
of all my different fields.
Since this data came in as a CSV,
they all were read in as word types or
strings, but as we know,
we have a few different variables
that are actually numeric.
So we should change those
field types to numeric types.
The other fields are find to leave as
categorical variables as word types or
strings.
After this, I want to go to my
data preparation category and
build estimation and validation samples,
using a create samples tool.
Within this tool, you choose how many
records, or the percent of records,
that you want to have in your estimation
sample, your validation sample and
the residual is the holdout sample.
So by default, I typically choose
70% for my estimation sample to
build my model off of, and 30% of my
data to then validate my model off of.
Anything left over that is less than
100% goes into my holdout sample.
As you can see 100% of my records
were consumed with the estimation and
validation samples, so nothing is going
to be within this holdout sample.
I'm going to run this workload right
now, so you're able to see it yourself.
What we can see is we have almost 1,600
records in our estimation sample.
So that's 70% of our records.
While the other 30% is in
our validation sample,
which is about almost 700 records.
And like I mentioned before, nothing
should be in our holdout sample, but
let me just confirm that now.
So now that we've changed field types as
well as creating different samples of
our dataset I want to bring in
a logistic regression tool now
to build up my first
logistic regression.
Let's first name the model.
We can name this whatever we want, but
I'll call it Hotel _Log.for
logistic regression.
And then I'm going to select my target
variable, and remember, the target
variables are what we're trying to
predict, so that's our redeemer field.
And then lastly, we'll select the
different potential predictor variables.
So, for this first run of the logistic
regression, I'm going to choose all
my different fields minus the customer
ID field since that's unique for
all my different customers.
The first name and last names, since I
highly doubt [SOUND] those have any sort
of predictive ability to my redeemer
field, as well as we need to
deselect our target field
which is the redeemer field.
I'm now going to bring out the browse
tool after our R, our report output,
so I'm able to view the results and
run the workflow down.
The other result is the O
which is the model object.
This is going to be use layer
to validate our model and
to score our model.
Now let's notice that the results
look exactly the same as they did for
our linear regression.
And they're used in
the exact same way actually.
The first thing I typically do,
is I go down to my R-squared value.
As you can see my R-square value
is at 0.6243, which is quite high.
Now, if we look a little closer at these
results, we notice that almost none of
the different variables are listed as
significant for our predictor variables.
We can see this because there's almost
no asterisks in the last column.
This is an indicator that this variable
is not very important to the model.
And it likely should not
be included at all or
it needs to be modified before it can
be effectively used within this model.